-Our next guest is an
Oscar-nominated
writer and director
behind movies like "Looper,"
"Star Wars: The Last Jedi,"
and "Knives Out."
His latest film, "Glass Onion,"
is streaming on Netflix.
And his new show, "Poker Face,"
is streaming on Peacock,
with new episodes
released on Thursdays.
Please welcome to the show
Rian Johnson, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you?
-I'm doing great, man.
Thank you so much for having me.
-I'm very excited to be
talking to you about
two different things that
you've recently worked on.
So, obviously,
we have "Glass Onion,"
which is the
"Knives Out" murder mystery,
and now this wonderful new show
with Natasha Lyonne.
So, one's a murder mystery.
One's a sort of
case-of-the-week-style show.
But they do seem
so intricly --
intricately, excuse me,
plotted that I'm wondering,
when you write these,
does that then make you better
at solving a murder mystery
if you're watching it
in someone else's movie?
-Oh, my God, no. No.
-Okay.
If I can pause the movie
and go away for eight months
and write the rest,
then I can figure it out.
But, no, I'm incredibly bad.
But that's actually -- I feel
like that's part of the way
I kind of approach these things
is, to me, always remembering
that when I do watch
a murder mystery,
I'm trying to figure out
and solve it
maybe for the first like
20 minutes,
and then I realize,
"I'm never going to solve this."
And I just wait for
the amazing solution
the detective gives at the end.
So the way I approach
writing these things is
remembering that and remembering
that the entertaining thing
isn't the audience
solving a puzzle.
It's got to be a roller coaster.
It's got to be funny.
It's got to be thrilling.
It's got to keep you engaged
moment to moment.
And then it's kind of
a bonus at the end
that you get kind of
a puzzle reveal.
So -- Yeah, so,
being bad at them
helps me is what I'm
trying to sell here, yeah.
-One thing they
have in common is,
I do think when you
talk about it being fun
and it being a roller coaster,
the people solving it
on-screen have to be
fun to watch.
You certainly have that
with Daniel Craig.
You have that with
Natasha Lyonne.
I've heard you refer to
the movie as a whodunit
and the TV show as a howdunit.
Can you explain the differences
between those two?
-You're asking the right man.
I can do that.
Yeah, so, whodunit, you've got
whatever, eight, nine suspects.
Any one of them
could have done it.
At the end, kapow,
it was this person, oh, my God.
How-catch-'em, which is how
I kind of have heard it
referred to -- Like, "Columbo"
is the most classic
kind of example of that.
And that's what we're doing
with "Poker Face,"
where we show you,
in the first act,
exactly who did it
and how they did it.
And then the whole thing
is kind of this
"Crime and Punishment"
cat-and-mouse game
between them and Natasha Lyonne,
how she's going to catch them.
And it's fun.
I mean, especially in
the hour-long format,
what that means is, when we get
great guest stars like --
We have, like, Nick Nolte
and Cherry Jones in an episode.
We've got Lil Rel Howery.
We've got, like,
an incredible --
That means that the entire
episode, they can own it.
We don't have to service
eight different people.
So it's great for the format,
you know.
-Certainly from
where I'm sitting,
you seem like
a very prolific writer.
Do you consider yourself someone
who enjoys the craft of writing?
-Oh, my God, no.
-By the way, thank you so much
for your honesty.
I feel like not enough
successful writers admit this.
-I feel so grateful.
I love what I do so much,
and that coexists perfectly with
absolutely being
miserable every moment
that I'm supposed to be writing.
And it's -- I don't know.
Do you -- When you write,
it's just procrastination.
-Oh, I hate it.
-It's guilt and misery, and
you're alone and eating poorly.
-Yeah. And then I would imagine
you have this
because you have to sort of
crack things, right?
Especially with
a murder mystery.
When you come up with
a solution to a problem
you've created for yourself,
do you get --
does your heart
start racing a little bit?
Do you get excited knowing,
"Oh, my gosh.
I think I've done it."
-You get maybe two of those
per writing process.
So over the course of a year,
there may be
two little moments of,
"Ah, eureka,"
and the rest of it, it's just...
-Yeah.
But isn't it -- But now let's
look at the other side of it.
Right now, here you are.
All you get to do, you know,
for the time you're out here
is talk about two things
you have finished.
Isn't that nice?
We're talking about
writing that's done.
Isn't that the best thing
in the world?
-I hate writing.
I love having written, yes.
When I can put on a suit
and come talk to you,
this is my happy place.
-Yeah. I'm assuming this is not
the suit you wear to write in.
-Every single day, man.
I'm like, this is...
-Now, your wife
used to be a film critic.
So, obviously, she has a --
you know, a very sharp eye
for what is good and bad
on-screen.
Does that mean that she gives
you feedback on your work?
-Well, yeah, my wife,
Karina Longworth,
she was a really successful
film critic.
She's now a film historian.
She has a podcast called
"You Must Remember This"
that's an incredible
Hollywood podcast.
And she also has
an incredible ability --
I think this is a skill.
She's absolutely incapable
of feigning interest
in something
she doesn't find interesting,
which I'm trying to
get better at, actually.
I've kept myself in
so many awkward situations
by feigning interest and, like,
because I thought it was polite.
And so -- But what that means
is, I -- And this is good.
I have to polish something
and make sure
it's really good before
I pitch it to her,
because I want her
to love it so much, yes.
-That's great.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I mean, I do think, ultimately,
if you had to choose
one or the other, you would
rather have someone you trust
than someone who tells you
everything you're doing
is great.
-Maybe, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
Depending on what phase
in the writing.
-Right. Exactly.
It must be so -- You know,
we're a huge fan,
good friends with Natasha
here on this show.
She's coming on tomorrow,
which I'm excited about.
Have you enjoyed
collaborating with her?
Because she has
a very unique voice.
-Oh, my God.
She's been the best.
And this is -- I mean,
that's been the fun thing
about this show is it's not like
I made the show and cast her.
This has been, you know,
a real collaboration.
And anyone who's
seen the show knows the show
is kind of made for her
like a bespoke suit.
It's really --
Everything about it is designed
because I love Natasha,
and it's all designed
to kind of strap a rocket
to the back of
what I love about Natasha
and get it straight to people,
so, yeah.
-Is there anything
you and Natasha do on set
that would be in line
with what we might expect from
someone like Natasha Lyonne?
-[ Laughs ]
Every single moment.
You know, one thing that --
So, one thing --
And this is fun
because this sounds absurd,
but there's a method behind the
madness, like much of Natasha.
We would -- In between takes,
we would start
driving the crew nuts by singing
the Meow Mix song to each other.
And then we started --
Just, like, any song
that would come on the radio,
for the next hour,
it would just be, like,
Led Zeppelin
done in the Meow Mix --
♪ Meow, meow, meow, meow ♪
Which -- But the thing is,
what she's --
I realized
it's actually important,
what she's doing there.
When you're making a movie,
there's so much carpentry,
and it's very easy to
get lost in the,
"We get this shot,
then we get this shot."
And her job
is to create something
that feels alive and spontaneous
in front of the camera.
And so when she does that or
when she riffs or makes jokes,
what she's doing,
it actually has a real purpose.
It's very smart.
It's keeping that
element of chaos alive
in between the takes
so it will be there
when we roll the cameras.
-It's very interesting
you point that out,
because, of course,
Natasha, on-screen,
has always made it look like it
just comes so naturally.
But, of course,
it has to be a controlled chaos.
Nobody -- Even that,
once it's on film,
it has to be considered,
it has to be a craft,
and she's so good at it.
-I mean, Natasha
and also, you know,
Daniel Craig as Benoit Blanc.
I mean, I've learned over
the past few years,
by observation,
if a performance feels breezy
and looks effortless, the actor
put a hell of a lot of work
into making that happen.
And having those folks,
being able to learn from
watching that
has been pretty cool.
-I should stress, like I said,
I also hate writing,
but the longer I worked with
the cast when I was on "SNL,"
like, the more you learn
their voices.
It didn't get easy,
but it got a little easier.
I got to imagine
the same thing happens
when you write for Daniel
a second time as Benoit Blanc,
when you write for Natasha
in current episodes
after seeing what she can do.
Does it get a little bit easier
knowing they can pull off stuff?
-Does it? I'm going to hope.
I'm going to -- I'm going to
hope you're right.
At some point,
this gets a little --
Yeah, I guess it kind of does,
but it also gets harder,
because the thing I described
in Natasha with the Meow,
I'm trying to do my own Meow Mix
when I'm writing,
because the last thing
I want to do
writing another Benoit Blanc
movie is to have it
be a photocopy of
his performance in the last one.
-Yeah, that's true.
Setting a high bar for yourself.
You blew it.
You should have
wrote some stinkers first.
You should have started with
some real bad duds, and then --
-Where were you
when I needed you? Yeah.
-Hey, congratulations on
both of them.
It's such a pleasure
to have you here.
-Thanks so much, Seth.
-I'm such a fan.
You guys, that's Rian Johnson.
"Glass Onion"
is streaming on Netflix,
and new episodes of "Poker Face"
stream Thursdays on Peacock.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."